[音楽]
突然ですが
みなさんには
今から
高校に入学してもらいます
後に学
おめでとうございます
歯が高校生活にワクワクしています
どんな高校生活が待っているんだろう
ドキドキも
もありません
ついに
学校生活が始まりました
周りの友人が
部活に入ったので
あなたは何となく一緒に入りました
そこから部活漬けの日々です
平日は毎日夜7時まで
土日も1日部活
そうこうしているうちに
定期テストがやってきました
なんとなく勉強していたら定期テストが終わりまた部活に打ち込む日々です
しかしまたすぐに次の定期テストがやってくる
このように
部活勉強
部活
勉強なんとなくやっていると
いつのまにか
あなたは
進路を考え始める時期になりました
周りに合わせ
とりあえず大学進学を決め
学部も名前だけを見て決めていると
あっという間に3年生が終わるべき
いつのまにかあなたは
高校
卒業してしまいました
を卒業
おめでとうございます
しかし
皆さん
振り返ってみてください
世界はこんなにもう
広いにも関わらず
3年間狭い学校の中で
なんとなく生活をしていた
実際皆さんが高校生だったころも
3年間の学校生活をただ
漠然と過ごしてきてはいませんでしたか
また
3年間の高校生活はすべて
校内だけ
少してきてはいませんでしたか
とほとんどの人がそうだったと思います
多くの高校生は先程のような
生活を送っており学校中心の
生活です
もちろん学校中心の生活は悪くはありません
しかし世界はとても広いにも関わらず
3年間をただ
学校内ばかりで過ごしてしまう
方向性が社会を知らないために社会に出る選択肢がない
ということは
とても問題だと思うのです
僕がそう思ったきっかけは
僕が中学生の頃にたまたま興味を持っていき参加した企業に関するイベントです
そこでは
高校生可
大人と堂々と話しをしていないとしてみました
同世代で起業している人や
世界を飛び回っている人もいる
そこで初めて僕は
方向性が社会に出ないことによって
可能性が狭まってしまっていると感じたのです
僕は今この場に登壇をしていますが
もし
あのイベントに参加していなければ
今でも
なんとなく他の高校生と同じように学校生活を送っていたと思います
そこから
学校内にこもっている高校生に
社会に出るという選択肢は与え
こう可能性を広げたいと
思い始めました
そこから
だから僕は
学校外に出る
と言う
高校生を増やすという取り組みを始めました
方向性が社会に一歩でも踏み出して
身近なボランティア活動
例えば
ゴミ拾いをするだけでも
環境問題や
ふう浦東大きな問題だと
さまざまな社会課題を見つけることができる
学校の中では教科書の中でしか
分からなかってこの
社会に出れば実際に経験することができます
社会に出ることで方向性のシェアは格段に広がり
広い考え方を持つことができるのです
そうすれば
将来の可能性も
広がり
高校卒業したその後の人生においても
選択肢が
広がります
では
どのようにすれば
高校生よ
社会に出すことができるのでしょうか
現状
高校生は
ほとんど社会に目をむけません
社会に何があるのか
わからないのです
また
今の高校生は
社会で安い
環境では
ないのです
僕はその環境を変えたいと思っています
そのためには学び街がありチャレンジに寛容な社会づくりが大切です
だから僕は
アクト愛知という団体を
運営しています
actor 市では
愛知県の高校生に向けて
学校外で行われているイベントや
ボランティア活動
インターンシップの情報や
同世代で実際に社会に出て活躍している
若者情報を web メディアを通して発信したり
高校生に向けてイベントを開催したりしています
また
高校生だけでなく
その他の学生の方や
大人の方など
さまざまな世代の方々が一緒に交流をする
といったような
コミュニティも作っています
その代表例が
クエストクラブ
そこでは高校生目線の意見や
大人目線の意見など
で置かれている立場が違った人々が
お互いに意見を出し合い
それぞれが今まで考えてこなかった
考え方やアイディアに出会うことができるのです
またクエストクラブでは
自分を一度
見つめ直し
見つけた
身近な趣味や興味などから
小さなプロジェクトというものを立ち上げていただき
自分の日々の行動
少し
でもいいので変えていただく
そういった
活動を
ています
このような活動を通して
普段から意識を持って行動をし
積極的な行動ができる人々を増やしています
このように悪退治を通して
高校生が気軽に出ることができる社会を作っているのです
僕が理想とする社会では高校生が
企業と一緒に製品をつくったり
高校生が社会人と同じように働いています
高校生の持つ突拍子のないアイディアから
っっ
それが社会に溢れ
イノベーションを起こしやすい
社会に
なるかもしれません
方向性の持つ柔軟な考え方というのは
高校生だけ長く
大人のシェアをも広げるでしょう
また
高校生の柔軟な考え方かは
とても革新的です
幅広い年代の方々がお互いに議論をする
こうして社会全体が活発になるのです
このように高校生が気軽に社会に出て
学校の中だけでなく社会で自らの可能性を広げることができる
方向性が
学校にとどまらず
社会でも活躍ができる
このような
社会は
理想的だとは思いませんか
そんな社会が実現できるよう
僕は
鈴木学校外で活動を続けようと思います
奥の理想とする社会を作り上げるためにはもちろん
高校生自身の
努力が必要ではありますか
ここにいる皆さんの
協力も
不可欠です
高校生が
社会に参加し
社会とつながり
可能性を広げることで
より社会が活発
あるのです
みなさんには
もう一度高校に入学していただこうと思います
後に学
おめでとうございます
花の高校生活にワクワクしています
どんな高校生活が待っているんだろう
ドキドキもたまりません
ついに
学校生活が始まりました
ある人は
学校外に出て
ボランティア活動で国際協力を行っています
またある人は自分の留学費用を稼ぐために
アルバイトしています
勉強熱心にやっている人もいます
もちろん
なぜやるかと
明確な理由を持って
高校卒業後の進路も
皆さん
一人一人がしっかりと考えた上で
大学進学する人
そのまま働く人など
それぞれが
様々な
進藤あゆみます
皆さんはこの
可能性に満ちあふれた方向生活を
どのように過ごそうとそう
思いますか
ありがとうございました
[拍手]